معركه باخموت التي وصفت بمفرمه اللحم طالت
اكثر من اي معركه اخرى خلال الحرب في
اوكرانيا معركه باخموت وخلال ثمانيه اشهر
كلفات كلا من روسيا وايضا اوكرانيا العديد
من الارواح ورغم هذه المده الطويله لم يتم
تحديد المنتصر وتضارب التصريحات بشان هويه
المسيطر فوسط نفي اوكراني اعلن مؤسس
مجموعه فادينار الروسيه
السيطره الكامله على باخمه شرقي اوكرانيا
قال ان قوته ستبدا مغادره المدينه الخميس
المقبل وستسلمها للجيش الروسي الجيش
الاوكراني من جانبه رد قائلا ان قوته لا
تزال صامده في باخمت فقد اكدت نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني حنا مليار في منشور عبر
تيليجرام اكدت ان القوات الاوكرانيه لا
تزال تحتفظ بالدفاع طول ضواحي المدينه
الصناعيه المسؤوله الاوكرانيه اضافت ان
قوات بلادها تسيطر حتى على بعض المنش
الصناعيه والبنى التحتيه في المنطقه
بالاضافه الى القطاع الخاص جدير بالذكر ان
باخم التقاع على بعد حوالي 20 كم من منطقه
لوجانس وكانت هدفا لموسكو وذلك منذ شهور
لذا فان الاستيلاء عليها سيمثل نجاحا طالا
انتظاره وسيحقق بعض المكاسب الاستراتيجيه
في حين ستعاني اوكرانيا من هزيمه سياسيه
ومعنويه بحسب خبراء طبعا هذا وتراجع ايضا
الرئيس الاوكراني عن الاعتراف بخساره
بخموت مؤكدا ان قوتي لا تزال موجوده في
المدينه انه لا يمكن اعتبار المدينه تحت
السيطره الروسيه زيلينسكي كان قال في وقت
سابق ضمنا بان قواته فقدت السيطره على
المدينه دعونا نتابع
اعتقد اننا فقدنا السيطره على مدينه
باخبورت لكن عليكم ان تفهموا انها تحولت
الى لا شيء الروس دمروها بالكامل لا يوجد
فيها بناء الامر ماساوي اليوم بامكاننا
القول ان باخموت فقط في قلوبنا لا يوجد
شيء هناك الا الدمار والكثير من القتل
الروس الذين اتوا الينا الاوكرانيون الذين
دافعوا عن بخموت قاموا بعمل قوي وبالطبع
نحن نقدرهم على جهودم رائعه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات